[Music]
yes so uh
we thought that henry might have been
the one that
chased us down in the beginning of the
game because in the beginning of the
game she was a little girl and she was
being chased through the woods
with some guy with a gun but he just
said that was thomas and that's our dad
and we found out that obviously sadness
is our sister and she's dead so how did
she die
was it richard so many questions let's
try and get them answered
okay marianne focus
this was your home once there's got to
be something here
so nothing else to look at or something
here
a family photo there they are it's sad
to see it like this
left behind forgotten
me daddy lillian and our little red
house
so nothing behind the portrait
just i think
you're thinking with my resident evil
hat on right now
another photo
oh that's how it gets wrong to just
leave them lying around
oh there's a doll's house is that a
dollhouse how the hell did it survive
the fire
locked maybe there's a way to open it
can't you just look through the um big
hole in the roof
no i guess i feel like i should find
somewhere to put it
oh wait am i supposed to put them all
next to each other oh like in a timed
order so
oh it won't be that one it would be
uh the wedding photo first and then
the uh this one and then all of them
together
i think that's it the rekovich family
history
puzzle queen
looking all burnt up but i can still
make out some of it
oh my god what the hell i just looked up
at the green bar
we've already nearly reached the goal
how did that happen
okay we'll go and check that out in
advance
i can't believe that what the hell we've
already been streaming for like five
minutes i'm gonna have to change the
goal guys
hey look at us go it's so good
why did we do this then what did this
actually do
blaine colin colin colin what did you do
i'm gonna i'm gonna go check it
in a bit
all right let's see what's on the flip
side of this place oh my god i can't
believe that
somebody's like give us a challenge okay
right while i'm playing then you guys
think of the
uh an appropriate goal that we should
reach because apparently
i underestimated us
strange thank you maria
feelings etched into the wall
is this my clue for the puzzle that i've
already done
i feel like it is hello this looks
eerily familiar that's scary that is
thank you maria pizza
[Music]
would you like me to put that towards
the charity
what's this we got giant heart here
as a horrible game dev itself does it
help you predict
jump scares that's a great question da
nan
jay and yes but also i jump every time
do you guys remember the people with uh
with the sexy bath time
i knew something was coming i still
jumped so hard it
doesn't make it any less scary not for
me anyway
but i feel like even if you play a lot
of horror games and watch a lot of
horror films you
get to learn the tropes withhold i think
that's what i love about horror
the the thing about horror isn't the
jump scare
it's not the monster it's it's not like
the actual tangible scary thing it's the
build-up
and that's that's the exciting part and
if you do it right that's
that's what horror is all about it's not
really so much about
what actually happens when you do look
under the bed or whatever
it's the suspense and the journey
between
realizing something might be under the
bed and then plucking up the courage to
look under the bed
that's what horror is all about oh i
love it anyway i'll stop talking
and ornate butterfly
okay so let's go back to
well i have that on my other side as
well on the normal side of me
that's true actually sydney said i've
only really screamed once in this game
that's my true maybe i am getting braver
can i put this butterfly here no okay
the dollhouse oh it's open it's open
it looks like a replica of the actual
house
oh looks like i could put something here
tiny mirror cute i wonder
a very oh wait oh
oh is this representing kind of the two
sides of a bedroom
strange it feels like something shifted
where can i go
what do i do that butterfly that i've
got as well i thought i would put it
down with the other butterflies but i
i guess not
can i go through here and then maybe
it'll take me to a different room
i knew it oh the doll has seen the
mirrors
it's all connected that's how pretty is
that
very familiar oh i freaking i love the
color scheme of this game
it's so nice oh maybe this is where i
put that
no mask
locked four slots
i guess that means four butterflies so
i've got one butterfly
there we go let's find three more
uh i've always wondered if first person
horror was better than fixed angles
what do you think great question um
well to be honest i've always wanted to
play another fixed angle horror game
but at the same time i mean because this
is very much like it
we've gotten so used to being being able
to control
um the your camera view that it's it's
very
jarring nowadays whereas before it was
just that was just the way the video
games were
um i do think that it it hinders
some of this particular game every now
and then because there were some
extremely annoying stealth uh stealth
mechanics
or stealth moments where because you had
a
fixed camera angle you couldn't really
use it to see
where you could hide to or
like knowing the right depth was quite
difficult at times so you wouldn't know
whether you could actually hide behind
something or whether it was blocked off
because
you couldn't turn your camera to see
that was very frustrating
whereas in uh the old resident evil
games
old-school hill games um i think it
worked better
because i used it in a way where you
couldn't see what was in front of you
but you could hear that it was right
behind the camera
and that's absolutely terrifying but the
the difference is that in sun hill and
resident evil you could actually
kill these things it wasn't about trying
to find the right place
to hide which was great because it's
hard to do that with a fixed camera
angle
um and all you had to do then is just
pluck up the courage
to go towards the place where you
couldn't see
and then hope that
whatever it was wasn't too big or too
close you just had to take that chance
and then try and time it right to like
shoot them but you're like aiming
towards the camera so it's quite jarring
and it's also just like it's very tense
because you don't have that control of
seeing what exactly is in front of you
um
i think people now might have less
patience for that because it's not
really the norm
but i i thought that worked really well
right now
obviously a lot of people are using
first person because it makes
it more immersive in theory because
obviously there's nothing in the way you
feel like it's just you
but i did really like that with the old
games
that's good i think um can i open up
this one as well
this one looks tough oh i don't think i
can cut through
okay fair enough there's nothing i can
put in here
it's got a little mask of joy whose mask
is that is that my mask no
oh it might be her no it doesn't look
like a face of a mother
oh i'm an idiot it's
lillian's it's sadness's face of joy
because she's not happy she's sadness
that's her
her happy face right i've got to be on
the right lines
uh okay so i think that's all i can look
at here so let's go back and go into the
other room
it's gonna be two two butterflies in
each room i guess
this room it feels like it's
pushing me out like it doesn't want me
here is it your old room
wait i don't think this belongs here
he's a fish what's the fish doing here
unless we out
okay let's get another butterfly i guess
oh come on
and another one i do really like that i
don't think that's going to get old
no well it's the end of the game no it
won't get old
oh i said something under my pillow i
hate you
all of you none of you know
none of you understand i
do what the frick is that
another mask
were those the friends satness talked
about
sounds bloody creepy to me i do
there's something underneath
what is this oh here we go a tea party
with the devil
[Applause]
creepy
i understand i
can feel your pain
what the hell yeah what the hell
we can show them
we can make them understand
make them feel what it's like
okay we don't have the last one yet uh
maybe we can give it a fish
fish head
okay this is creepy
okay we have more
to figure out here
oh thanks antoine i didn't have a date
for valentine's day so i decided to
invite my mum out because
she deserves it unfortunately to me she
does have a date
ah oh that's so cute
but surely she can she can go out with
you both right
no i don't know that's really sweet of
me though oh bless
bless you in your mum's eh
well at least you can watch this stream
right
what do i do with this fish toy guys
for some reason that picture frame is
still highlighting even though you can't
interact with it
yeah true i noticed that after i said it
jamie that that actually might be
uh maybe i can go back into the
initial room maybe there's something
there
is there anything here oh hello
i can't stand the look she gives her she
hates her because of what happened to
you
she thinks it's her fault as if she did
it on purpose
she's still too young she needs time to
understand
but sometimes i'm afraid a afraid she'll
do something to her
i keep telling myself she would never
but then again
i know better than anyone everyone has
their demons
third wheel on your mum's data
i'm pretty sure i've been a third wheel
on my mum's dates before well
not dates
no i haven't actually
but i do like ruin it sometimes when i'm
home because i'm not home very often
i'll just be like can we watch this film
instead of whatever coronation street or
whatever
my mom's like of course you're not
you're not here after my stepdad's like
grumble grumble grumble
and i'm like um
so i think that was just
a hint for the other thing that we
where is this final mask then was is it
not in the fireplace
you would have thought it would have
been put in the fireplace like when we
completed that sequence of pictures
final mask where are you
why can i keep looking here when there's
nothing to see
i can't even pick up this butterfly
oops
ah this one
says fishes for another room near the
flash blob you couldn't cut
so i guess i put the fish here i don't
need her
she took my mom away from me i hate her
i wish she was dead lily i
no it was not my fault wait did she kill
her mom
what the hell's happening to me
oh my god that's the last of them
nothing i must have messed it up somehow
uh how would i know the sequence i guess
i could just look at the
silhouettes yeah
right so the smallest one i think is
this one yeah
uh there's a pointy one
that's a pointy one or is that the
pointy one
that's the pointy one
save yourself let me
help you
did we do something
or was it i'm getting very confused
whether this monster is talking to
a younger version of marianne or lillian
this oh sorry but i didn't but i doubt
um
but but i can't leave her here she'll
die
remember mommy
it's all her fault no
no no she's my sister then
set me free and i will
save you both
[Music]
that thing it came from her
bought its way out with our lives
lily she
i need to find her
lillian
oh my god it's so dark
i think the brightness is up for you
guys i don't know i can't see it very
well
huh the basement looks almost
intact maybe i'll find some clues down
here
daddy where is marianne
she needs to stay at the hospital a
while longer
will she be all right i want to see her
she's asleep honey
the doctors aren't sure when she's gonna
wake up
i was in a coma that's why i couldn't
remember anything
was that after running through the woods
no no i couldn't have been because
that must have happened straight after
the house fire oh gosh
apparently i'm not looking directly at
it yet
come on
i am looking right at it
lily listen
you have to come with me now daddy
where are you taking me
i'm sorry baby
i'm so sorry thomas
what the hell did you do to her
that's a big needle
she's sick but it's not physical he was
right
that terrible night something has
awakened
something was born inside her it's
eating her from the inside
preying on her strength her little body
with us i have to do something
we need to do something so
if her if the if i'm if i
am reading this correctly uh the mayor
or whatever it's called
came out of liliane is is that the mayor
that came from her because i know she
said it came from this
like the sadness of everyone who had
died
but maybe it came from her and maybe
they are one in the same so maybe that's
why she can't leave
i'm nothing sad
wait did i miss anything
jesus this thing is serious okay looks
like it's military
solid steel combination lock
the more sorry the more
tell me about the fire lily
you were locked in alone no
we were not alone no
who else was there the voice
um i i didn't invite it but
it came anyway
oh lily
anything around here is this where it
came from
yeah okay but there's another door
maybe you're right here
he's out there somewhere that much i
know hell
the fact i'm sitting here writing this
and not drooling in the corner is proof
enough
i just gotta find him funny i always
wanted to be
alone the only one now i'm starting to
think there were never really two of us
maybe we were always just two sides of
the same coin
either way i need him i need to i need
myself
to save her oh so he's talking about
the weird two sides of him wait
so was the voice they were hearing
like the other side of them because
that's what always confused me
marianne seems to be just herself in one
dimension or the other
but thomas seems to have like two funny
split versions of himself they're
always present
today's her birthday 27th of february
it always brings me back to that moment
the first time i saw her that wonderful
tiny creature
at the time i'd do anything just to be
her dad
to sit to silence that other part of me
but now
i'm desperately trying to bring it back
to help her to save her
i think i've finally figured out a way
it's risky but it's our only chance
if it fails no it will work it has to
work
so did she get lost wait was this me was
marianne lost in like
the other world and that's why she was
in a coma for so long
possibly
but what did he do to lillian
tell me about the fire lily no no
but the voice
tell me about the fire lily
um
the door here
fairly legible but
i can still make out some of it
receipts matter of time watch shop
krakow watch shop
okay why do i need to know that
watch
a lot of love was put into this oh
here's a what
stop there's sadness too
ten years time flies huh here's a little
something to keep you
keep to help keep help you keep track
i love you big dummy
thanks for following manchu menchu
mian
can i not look behind this
i guess not wait
now i know anniversary wait 2702 so it
might be 2702 or it might be
10 years uh that doesn't actually have a
date it doesn't
it might be 2702 then unless it's on
here
uh
10 years
i'm gonna write this down because i'm
gonna forget um
[Music]
no why am i singing that uh so it could
be
2702 or it could be
what like 1966 because it's 10-year
anniversary right
or it could be 1404 but very unlikely
um it's probably either going to be 2702
or 1966.
stop dante yes this should be the
ending michael
okay so let's try 2702 first
no 1966.
there you go
for [ __ ] sake
it all ends in me
[ __ ] what will it take to get
rid of that [ __ ] thing i think you
have to get rid of lillian i don't know
that's just a
theory it's done they'll never know
they can never know they wouldn't
understand they would never forgive me
but they're safe that's what no we're
not
thomas separation is the only way so
what like something happens when they
come together or something something bad
yeah okay we need to find
uh
it's here can we go through here
here
what is this place some sort of a
fallout shelter fall out
it come on
this isn't
[Music]
there that looks like a way out
but it's half under water
that does not look like a way out for me
[Music]
can i go this way as heck
bloody sea
oh nice
well this place goes on forever
look at this
woohoo all right i need to go back now
so there's already nothing there
ah
maybe if i do this oh here we go
now we can go back and power up that
thing
well there's a generator all the way
back though that we can power up as well
okay well let's do this one first
nope oh that was weird
did you see that
just flash the medium
um
uh
i don't know what that just did though
i'm gonna go back and do the other one
um well we haven't gone down here yet
but it feels like there's so many places
to go
ah lower levels are flooded
i'm not much of a diver what about in
the other world
really all that just for that
yeah michael so if
if the path is blocked in one world then
it will be blocked in the other as well
because
this is the difference between her and
thomas her and thomas are like two
separate people that can live
in each um kind of alternate universe i
guess
um whereas she is still
one person she can only be at one place
actually that's not true because she can
she can meditate but then only for a
limited amount of time did that not work
[ __ ] i mean
what fine
stupid
the window sound scared me
[Music]
oh my god that's the thing when you get
fruit any fruit
even berries you never know whether it's
going to be bitter
sour sweet
[Music]
i could probably go down there with my
um
my ghosty self oh damn
there's so many places to explore here
maybe i could pump out the water from
[Music]
here
when we first stumbled upon the site we
thought it was just an old german bunker
a couple corridors maybe some outdated
supplies
two weeks of excavation later we knew
that old funny mustachio must have had
big plans for this place
a whole system of underground tunnels
reinforced concrete rules the whole
shebang
guess he wanted to have himself a little
forest retreat in case the whole master
race thing didn't work out
the companies did what they do best
sold it for themselves they wanted to
repurpose it into a full-on nuclear
shelter
they even got a power cord going but
that's as far as they got before the
dream of nemo went to [ __ ]
luckily for me the entire thing was very
hush-hush and i made sure
it stayed that way as far as i know most
people who knew about it
died in the massacre i wouldn't exactly
call it a silver lining but
still if things go south we should have
a
place to lay low who's this that's
troubled
so thomas
great great yes glad you saw a silver
[Music]
lining
oh [ __ ] looks like both retention tanks
are closed off
maybe i could get down there and open
them manually
oops
[Music]
what am i doing pressing the button
okay so i need to open up those tanks
manually
but i have got some water hours okay
let's get a layable land
[Music]
no i don't want don't worry tana um that
panel i think it's for like later or
something
to press x or a was just to like look at
it
in more detail
but the um what's for the like fungus
whatever
it should have gone away after using
that
i think there's something else i have to
do with it
hello
that was kind of cool seeing the door
open
there you go see
wow that's cool we've just gone all the
way around it
okay let's get back then i guess
yes we definitely yeah push the big red
button
i mean in a video game what do you have
to lose really
hello why can't i go through here hello
hello what why not
some bloody reason i can't walk through
the doorway anymore i guess i have to go
the long way around
dd from jokes
[Music]
to smear
[Music]
oh yeah can i go down here i know i
can't
in the real world oh maybe i can now
because i kind of drained it a little
bit didn't i
yeah it looks good
hello
thank you very much
does not look stable
at least the water isn't in the spirit
world i guess the spirit world looks
like it's underwater constantly anyway
wow
why
hello can i go this way
nope what
nothing here for me
see this is also the thing with a fixed
camera angle sometimes it is extremely
hard to know
where you can go and where you can't
damn i think i'm getting lost
remember i think it was in the first
episode i got lost because i couldn't
find um
a bloody hallway
in a corner that was
hidden wise probably not on purpose but
it was behind a pillar
and i just couldn't see it in the fixed
camera angle
so this is running around in circles
like balloons where am i supposed to go
nothing around here
hey virtual turtle games
happy love day
look we've already like nearly nearly
reached 200
that's crazy you guys are the best
oh isn't this where we were before oh my
god
this place like a little maze
okay how do i get back around
ah ah i wish i had a map
do i have a map
i don't have a map that'd be lovely
this is some weird ass reason i can't
go back around again the way that i
first came in
[Music]
can i get everything into here and then
i can go this side
okay oh now i get why i couldn't go
around there
it was because i think it was flooded
because it was at the top
right okay maybe hopefully we can go
back there now although that was weird
there should have been something to tell
me that
nothing's my
i'm goal if
not for me not for
me where would you
be what
would you be
dead you
owe me okay
so that thing michael is called the uh
the
i always want to call it the mayor is it
matt
and i think it might have actually come
from
i don't really know i think it's
attached to sadness which is the little
girl who's actually our sister
it might be in some weird way attached
to his boat i'm not quite sure
here we go
there oh it's ready to gulp down some
water
where's the uh
ah here we go
right i'm gonna have a toilet break guys
i'm drinking coffee
and if i have another one this is just
what happens ah
coffee goes right through me
so i will see you in a little a little
bit a little bit i'll be right back
hello okay we're back i'm just going to
check out the um
just giving page to see
to see what's happening here so
we have bloody hell it was a hundred
pound
colin thank you so much colin that is
so nice i don't know if you're still
here but i just want to say
thank you thank you thank you so much
we're the 25 pound for gift day jesus
christ
someone's feeling generous this
valentine's day
and then we have 10 pound from nicki
thank you so much
nikki 20 pound from samba jones
loneliness is truly sad time for all
glad there's a service to help that i
absolutely agree and thank you all for
being so bloody generous
um i got uh
five pound from maria didn't i i think
i'm gonna have to look at how much
youtube takes of that
so i think that's about like maybe about
like three pound for this so i will add
that on
i'm gonna write anything down that i get
that i need to add to it i'm going to
write down so i don't forget
and i will do that after well probably
during the break that we have
after this game but yeah
we're doing so well well wait wait until
we reach the target
and then if we want to up it well no
we'll probably
up because it's still quite early on but
thank you thank you thank you so much to
everyone who is
um taking part already really really
appreciate it
okay let's get back to the game
okay so we've done one we need to do the
other one now
she started to scream a little bit later
i'm so glad you're here
never enough never full
never wonder
you cut from the same cloth
is an old one alright
for
maybe i can kill it with this thing
just let me yes
okay nice one i did wonder why that was
there
it makes sense now because we know that
he doesn't like electricity
okay let's do this guys
so we can put the water into the water
tank
[Music]
can't go back that way now
so far so good now i can get to the
other tank
okay
okay so i'm just worried that like
whenever it starts chasing me up oops
i'm gonna forget where to go and then
i'm gonna forget where this is
and then because obviously this is how i
kill it but hopefully the game will make
you just super obvious and he'll come at
the right time and i'll just know
to impress it
oh here we go
ugh
if we've actually been down here before
but only in the ghosty world oh hello
[ __ ] oh the valve is missing
the valve is missing please be around
valve
said everyone when waiting for her
flight
oh i'm so funny no jokes
um
it's like drums
hey that's my way out
once i dry it up a bit oh okay cool cool
good tonight
the halloween episode where homer got
stuck inside of this event that sounds
terrifying
i don't remember that
that's it second tank ready for duty
right okay this must be the time where i
have to electrify
pretty pretty girls
so many dolls to play with
such pretty things to work i'm walking
towards it
she insatiable
in him the only one to
get away but they don't
last they've
never lost
but you will why will i like what's so
special about me thank you
what did i just think
oh god i'm lost already how do i get
back to the electrifying baby
[Music]
help
i knew this is gonna happen here we go
i just went the wrong way
come on then no not this time
not today
[Music]
it's gonna be as i come out oh hello i
don't even look at that
[Music]
i don't need it i'm too clever
move again yes
the central chamber's open get your ass
down there
marianne
is he not gonna come why did we have
this
i'm just gonna leave it on hopefully
he'll come
oh someone opened the door for us that's
nice
[Music]
let them see let them know
let them feel our
pain
it all lands in me
huh ugh i'm just really not a fan of
these stealth parts it's just
so not intuitive i just don't know where
the [ __ ] girl i don't
know because
it looks like i'm supposed to go through
that door in the ghost world
but he's looking there constantly he's
not turned around is he
no more shame
never again
let them look let them see
let them know let them
feel our pain
[Music]
uh
i'm probably gonna die a few times in me
oh yeah i could blast them i guess i
think i've got some energy
shame never
again let them look
let them see let them know
my opinion on these
i like them i just don't think it's used
very well in this game i'm sorry this is
like the
bit that i really don't like
but we can't
how do they get back
i like the idea of using your ghost self
to try and lure him out but that was
[ __ ] ridiculous he came back so
[ __ ] quick what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't feel like you have enough
options
i don't feel like the level is designed
for either there's never like
multiple places multiple decisions to
like
sneak around never that
there's like one maybe
[Music]
get back choice
see you you can't even tell that that's
actually a dead end
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm looking at the
wrong place
he didn't take he didn't come back as
quickly this time
that was weird last time he came back so
quick
really oh is that true excellent i
actually did i i'm
not gonna lie i didn't look at that you
were here i think blue between be great
to work with just saying
their intentions are good but i agree
the level design
doesn't go with the stealth elements of
this game
it's it's frustrated me a lot i'm sure
you guys can tell
i just don't like not having options uh
especially because i did play
last of us two recently and oh my god
the level design
on all of naughty dogs games are like
top-notch and um
i love i love the level design now
actually
that they did a great job of like making
the game
seem open world um
when it was actually relatively linear
but
it seemed open well but in a
non-overwhelming way
and they did that by placement of
objects
in the level and also lighting and
um it was just like even if it was an
open
space like say you're in a massive car
park or whatever it was so
obvious where you were supposed to go uh
just by like tiny little nuances
uh they're just very good at that but
anyway um so i guess
and because there was some stealth
gameplay in that game as well
i'm just so used to having loads of
options
but that to be fair this is a very
linear game anyway
oh [ __ ] i just blew it don't do this to
me
i turned too many things on
oh no what's so dark
yeah i agree none of it i agree i think
um this game it's got a good
good narrative although i will talk i'll
talk more about this later but
i just think some of the gameplay is
laying it down a little bit but i love
love love like the idea of the
the parallel worlds and stuff i would
like to see more of what i just
saw done better but like where you can
use your split self in i mean they've
done it well in puzzles
i'll give it that the puzzles are good
um but yeah
in like combat or stealth play uh
yeah because that's the thing like in
games like uh
outlast and stuff i mean outlast
has its own flaws but they
the stealth element was was better uh
and
uh the evil within even though the evil
within you can kill things as well but
the stealth element is better because um
you know you can like
hide in lockers or under beds and uh
there's more places to hide and the
the animation sequence like uh the the
walking cycle and stuff of
of the enemies are easier to read
you can usually uh
have time to uh
survey them and see what they're doing
before you then make your decision
of uh where to hide when to move
you know where to go where not to go
whereas with a lot of these style
sequences like you just saw
i'll just stay still in the most obvious
hiding spot which is usually the only
one
given to you and if you stay there for
too long he walks up to you and you're
found anyway so
you're not really given that time to
survey anything
uh and that's i think pivotal in the
stealth game i mean
anyway let's stop rambling and just
carry on talking
um here's what i know i think i know
the powers come from the same place but
they can manifest manifest in
different ways she seems to exist in
both places as if her mind can inhabit
two bodies at the same time
to her whatever happens in one place
affects the other
does she see the line between the two or
are they one and the same
oh this is marianne it's gotta be
new hypothesis death thins out the veil
between worlds so
that a new born mind never has to split
makes sense
in a weird [ __ ] up way death thins out
the veil
what do you mean death like death of her
mum did she die in that coma
hmm maybe i don't know
you gonna comment on that marianne
no okay hey i know this one
used to be one of my favorites you like
your
your moths and your butterflies aren't
you
is that all there is something over here
vitamins antibiotics
neuroleptics antidepressants
even by my standards that's a lot of
pills
[Music]
i might make another coffee
you i'd like to see co-op horror games i
know it's pretty hard
from the inside but phasmophobia is
bloody great
oh yes
i got fly in my room
how did that get busted open this was
definitely lily's place
she had a place in the bunker
oh look it's the more
i keep calling it matt it's the more
are these ladies drawings because
they're brilliant
oh it's cold cold shivers
salt who knew it was that simple a bit
of alchemy
some spiritual infusion and there you
have it looks like the folk tales were
true after all
anyway the room is ready and it works it
actually works
it's the first time in my life i feel i
can feel alone
it feels [ __ ] wonderful what why
oh right
if you use salt then the ghosts
will leave your lens and maybe that's
what we have to do to the more
ah she'd be a grown woman
by now but the room is still all
dolls and unicorns yeah because she died
when she was younger right
quite this election so she could doll
herself up
with no one to see her
maybe he meant well but somehow this
just feels sadistic
little windows into the world
it's something i guess sunshine doesn't
really
translate to text though
again with the salt the whole room is
lined with it
came with the spirits imagine being
locked up in this place
having a needle shoved into your arm day
in and day out
you didn't deserve this lily i mean lily
where were we were we i guess we were
gone
we're still in a coma how long were we
in that bloody coma for
is that a door can we not go through it
if we can find some salt then
maybe it will help how did that happen
okay maybe we can maybe we have the part
here we go burnt to a crisp
i guess i should look for a spare i got
one dude
okay
i don't want to do it again
oh my baby
let there be light
is that door just open did we come
through that from that door
huh bathroom
does it stay there don't i can't read it
what does it look smoky like someone's
been here
that definitely sounds like saturn hill
music
i want to pull back the curtain
[Music]
my heart
looks like he could never quite let go
of his passion
in another life
[Music]
she almost saw me today she sensed me i
should have known
i need to be more careful keep my disc
distance
not a day goes by that i don't think of
him
i know i did the right thing leaving her
at the hospital ah marianne
it's better this way she's better this
way but i keep
thinking of the day when it finally
happens when she discovers
what she really is i'll be she'll be
confused
afraid i should be there for her to help
her to make sense of it all
tell her it's all right no she'll make
it through
she's strong just like her mother
the dude that took her in after she came
out of the hospital
so he had his contact details and he was
going to bring i guess but he wrote on
it don't to remind himself not to play
[Music]
shows
[Music]
whatever he was working on the monster
[Music]
well it sounds like he was trying to get
the monster away
because that's why he's put salt
everywhere
i guess the monster was just drawn to
mariana lilly
hypothesis when experiencing trauma
the soul can split into two separate
entities in order to
mitigate the damage observation the
entities can remain
friendly agreeable or turn hostile
towards
each other how to destroy one without
drawing destroying the other
the more is totally lily right
i don't know what the trauma was exactly
maybe something to do with
the mum like did marianne
do something to the mom because she was
like
angry at marianne i don't know
so so many questions but it's gonna be
[Applause]
[Music]
says
[Music]
[Music]
bloody jolt on the chair that wasn't
there before was it
[Music]
we
[Music]
where are we going
[Music]
that now very cinematic very nice nice
little inclusion
nice decor very
minimalist oh god don't don't
repeat please huh
mold it looks pretty fresh
someone's been here recently wait is
this the table that she's talking to us
on at the like in the um you know the
midway points in the game because she's
there with a with a cup like that
two cups actually
huh
[Music]
if i find enough pieces i might be able
to get to the other side
okay better get to it alice
alice through the looking glass let's
see what you did there
yeah i know i can tell the music off
i'll go back in a bit
it's quiet now just me and her just me
and her it feels strange but in a good
way
how it should be i best enjoy it while
it lasts
already started moving the workshop over
to the hotel
if anything happens i don't want her
anywhere near it i'm going in
to get him back so the other thomas
this only ends in one of two ways either
both of us are coming back
or neither
so is he trying to destroy his
other self i'm so confused now because
now i'm like okay where does richard
come into any of this
because i thought richard killed lillian
but i guess not
oh maybe that was the trauma that she
experienced that
made her create the more
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
very nice thank you okay
here's one so far so good
okay so i guess the glass shards were
always there but we
just weren't looking for them so
we couldn't pick them up before there
another one or maybe they've just
randomly appeared
the mall is just like let me help you
there's gonna be one in her room
charlotte
we haven't seen him in so long now
maybe not maybe there wasn't one here
no i was mistaken there is not one here
i think we've got to pick up three
though right oops
come on
can i go this way
that's where it came doesn't it yeah
glass any glass
for some glass
class class
this should be enough let's make magic
happen
and there it was the moment we
finally met
oh
thomas daddy
yes wait
you're the other one the spirit
but the hound
i thought you were gone gone
no no
trapped i know i
spent years in henry's
[ __ ] up world oh he's stuck in henry's
world when you
oh i could
i could finally break free
[Music]
good that's
why you're so important you
can finish this where's the real thomas
then is he dead
yeah where is my father okay ask the
right questions
i don't know
for um first time in my life
i i don't feel
his presence
i've been away for so long
could you
could you stay for a moment
tell me how
i'm all this started
that's who she's speaking to right in
the cutscenes
over the table
[Music]
it all starts with a dead girl
nice i like that i like that
what about lily
did my father
no he couldn't have
he wouldn't he loved her too much
both of you
so what happened to her
what is this place this is where he kept
her
that cell back there
it only exists in one world
keeps the other one out
he built it so that he could be alone
it's the only place he could feel
separated from his powers
for me
came in handy once lily became
unstable
unstable what do you mean
she's a medium too mario
a powerful one
i guess it runs in the family
what about mumzy when richard
when richard hurt her
it woke something inside her
something something terrible
it was only a matter of time before it
got out
it's what your father feared
what are you trying to avoid that's
why he called me
but that means yes
she's still alive there's still a way to
save her
you have to find her marianne where is
she
where is my sister so we've just been
seeing her
her other version of herself
what i don't know i searched the bedroom
the lake what
what's in the leg
how do i know she's in the lake that
makes no sense why would i know she's in
them like long as i can i'm not leaving
you
[Music]
butterfly
trust me
i'm sorry what did he just do to her
where is he pusher
no richard didn't kill her but but
richard did awaken oh no
i know
i personally i don't think it was like
the monster inside richard that like
killed things i think the monster was
richard you know i mean like the dark
side of everyone
i don't think it was like a outside
force that's just my opinion
i guess it's up to interpretation
but i think these monsters are just like
they're actually formed within people
from their own
decisions and like innate
disgusting wants and desires
this is it
but this time
something is different
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's pretty that's really pretty
i'm getting close i can feel it
i can feel it so clearly now
[Music]
[Music]
against
[Music]
to find
you finally made it how long has she
even stood there
i've been waiting for you little sister
i thought you were the little sister
lily i
i didn't know
i couldn't remember i'm so sorry
it's okay
it was better that way
at least you had a life
for a while
oh yeah that day oh the other half of
her necklace last day
when the fire broke out at our house
i made a deal
a part of my soul
that was tormented
was set loose
you mean the monster but why
to save you
[Music]
it helped us escape the flames
but in return i had to set it free
free to devour to destroy
to kill
[Music]
the naval massacre yes
all those people died
so that we could live
that's not great really because i lived
so did my demons
father knew my powers
were too dangerous
he left you at the hospital so you could
have a normal life
[Music]
and what about you
did he try to no
maybe he should have
[Music]
but he couldn't bring himself to do it
instead he locked me away
but he only delayed the inevitable
monster it got out
and now you're here
you're the only one who can fix this
how can how come she can't fix it
because the monster's tied to her i
guess we both
share our father's gifts but also his
fate
and the dream
the dream but
all i see is a girl you
shot dead here on this pier oh my god
are you the one that's gonna shoot her
hasn't it already happened
no
it's not the past you see
it's the future the dream
that's what i want to have what i want
to happen but you're running away
from the person shooting you so if you
want it to happen
it all ends in me
but no no
you can't send a spirit away while the
host is still alive
that's why you couldn't destroy the
monster
that's why sadness didn't want to go
but you're my sister that's why it has
to be you
i i'm not strong enough
it won't let me
only you can end this
only you can fix what our father could
not
leanna i can't
please don't make me do this it's the
only way to destroy it
to prevent further bloodshed really
what's going on
almost
i'm your only chance aren't i
you need a medium strong enough to
sustain you
for the others they only lasted for so
long before you broke them down
marianne please i don't want
maybe it's not your choice maybe
this is my story after all
no don't do this
please sister set me free
stay back stay back
you can't only save butterfly
who died did she kill herself she killed
herself
it all starts with a dead girl
she she definitely what
what no
you can't leave all my other flag
what
[Music]
damn
they only had one game designer what
it's crazy what
[Music]
three writers narrative designers
three narrative designers
voices i'm always interested you know
what
narrative designers do in other studios
because like in some studios the writers
are basically the narrative designers
then in some like this you've got three
writers and then just
i'm guessing he's like designing
mechanics that go with the writing what
can i break
anyway um voices
all around me there's gonna be an after
credit whisper
too let's hope so we will someone may
sit around and watch there's gonna be an
hour this is
[Music]
i was like saying that last time we
played it i was like does it sound like
him
i'd love to see is there actually a
video of him doing the voices
for the more i'd love to see that
because i want to see what it sounded
like
[Music]
[Music]
keep ringing in my head and these voices
in my
soul know that i'm not in control
let me go let go
no one ever has to
know
[Music]
crying tears in isolation
what's your opinion i think
[Music]
breaks the silences
[Music]
from my own humanity
[Music]
lived unclear
[Music]
is
[Music]
times out
[Music]
know
[Music]
screaming breaks the silences
[Music]
[Music]
we're ashamed of or we feel guilty by
all things
and these voices she
had uh she basically said that she was
treated badly by her dad in serious ways
but it didn't go too far into that it
was just more up to interpretation
anyway yeah
oh no you didn't hear me oh well
uh what
yeah yeah yeah later here we go
oh it's the stopwatch
for the anniversary
it's gotta be thomas right
okay what does that mean i don't know
this is cool
so creepy
oh yeah oh it's so creepy
so basically what i was saying was uh
with the narrative
i feel like it was good um i i think i
said this last episode i know what and
some people have
interpreted it as uh there is external
forces going into people and making them
do bad things so therefore like it's not
their fault because they had a monster
inside them but i don't see it like that
way i think i think it's the
the monster is created from within the
person and the choices that they
make and things like that um but i feel
like
it's not as impactful as say sun hill
2's narrative because
silent hill 2 was
um about a man who was struggling
with his internal guilt about not being
there for his
wife in her final days um
and fighting with the innate desires
that he has
as like a human being and a man and you
know
sexual needs and things like that he
knows what he should do but he can't
help what he wants to do
and that's the kind of parallels and
then you have obviously the the
characters that you meet along the way
who have their own struggles
um with what happened in their in their
childhood
um or something like that you know
being bullied and how that's manifested
into
this like hatred that makes them want to
kill people
or you know the girl who obviously was
treated
not so good by her dad and that's that
that fear of that moment
has actually turned into a boss battle
itself
like i think that's way more um
compelling just because it's it's not as
big as like nazis
or um you know like
proper
the topics that were talked about here
they're so big topics and there was a
couple of different ones that were like
huge um but because they're so big
they're not as easily
relatable to the person playing
i think that's what i'm trying to get to
as a you know as
as a narrative um i think i feel like
everyone can play sandhill too
and in some way feel like they can
relate
to feeling guilty about
uh something that they can't control
about themselves
whether that be a decision that they've
made in the past or
you know a desire or a need that they
want that makes them
selfish but it's what makes us human
you know we make mistakes and sometimes
they can
they can lead to like really bad places
that we didn't expect it to go
but anyway that's why sun hill was um
quite impactful uh
but saying that this narrative was good
i do think it's not it's not the best
game to stream
because i think you need to spend a lot
like
you need to actually pay attention to
everything
um so i'll probably have to like watch a
few videos to make sure i've like
got the right yeah everything's all the
loose ends are like tied up and stuff
but yeah i think she killed herself at
the end of the day i think she killed
herself
because she's so right the more wanted
her the more i didn't really care about
her sister anymore
um the moore didn't care about her
sister anymore
and then her sister oddly started to
show
signs of selfishness at the end anyway
because she was like poke me out of my
misery like you know like save me
i was like okay it's just about you i
mean i get it because obviously she
kills herself then her sister's
left to remain there i'm guessing unless
could she not kill herself as well i
don't know
um but yeah that's what i think happened
but ultimately i had really good fun
playing that and let's have a look at
the
um the just giving page because it looks
like
we might have reached
reached our goal let's have a little
look
oh hell yeah we reached the goal
okay